[Musique]
marie-christine le tarnec bienvenue
toujours à ça les vaut bienvenue pour ce
café politique votre café politique vous
êtes la mère de guyancourt et surtout on
va commencer par ça vous êtes toujours
encarté au parti socialiste
alors c'est presque devenu rare
aujourd'hui pourquoi ce choix non c'est
pas sépare alors c'est vrai qu'à un
moment j'ai j'ai souhaité quand je suis
devenue adjointe au maire et en sorte
que mon engagement politique soit
officiel donc j'ai pris effectivement ma
carte au parti socialiste
maintenant je me retrouve quand même
site un parti de gauche donc je me
retrouve dans les valeurs que ce parti
porte entre autres bien la défense des
services publics la solidarité faire en
sorte que les il n'ya plus l'inégalité
la ligne incarné par l'ancien
responsable en tant que département du
parti socialiste la ligne incarné par
benoît hamon qui aujourd'hui a fondé son
nouveau mouvement génération point s
vous ne vous y retrouver pas alors ce
sont des hommes de goût des hommes et
des femmes de gauche
il est bien vrai cette division de la
gauche peut-être aussi alors je déplore
effectivement après tous les partis sont
pareils on n'a pas c'est vrai que
l'année dernière le
moment des élections au niveau des
élections présidentielles les électeurs
bien ont rejeté complètement les parts
historique
et puis pour les législatives ne sont
pas venus voter donc ça nous pose
question après je regrette effectivement
toutes ses divisions
donc j'espère que de toute façon je
pense que toutes ces personnes là qu'ils
ont fait dès qu'ils ont choisi des voies
différentes
on se retrouvera systématiquement quand
ce sera pour la défense du service
public quand ça sera pour effectivement
des valeurs de solidarité
on se retrouvera on se retrouvera
puisqu'on restera des des femmes et des
hommes de gauche qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de vous engager en politique
l'arrivée au sein du conseil municipal à
guyancourt c'était en 2008
alors si je refais un petit peu le
rétroplanning de tout ça j'ai toujours
eu envie de m'engager sur différents
sujets je trouve que c'est important de
donner du temps pour les autres et
bon j'ai déjà eu une longue alors déjà
effectivement au niveau de mes parents
une mère engagée dans une fédération de
parents d'élèves ce qui n'était pas
effectivement évident à l'époque j'ai eu
la chance de faire une scolarité dans
une école freiner donc ça apprend le
sens des responsabilités les décisions
collectives puisque voilà on était
libres effectivement nous après j'ai
fait des études dans un lycée agricole
300 garçons cinq filles
donc il a fallu trouver des moyens de se
faire respecter pour moi c'est passer
par un engagement au foyer des élèves
jusqu'à en prendre la présidence
après bon une arrivée en région
parisienne où je me suis aussi engagé au
niveau d'un syndicat dans mon institut
et puis quand on est enfant nos enfants
sont arrivés à l'école bien les nez
quand il est arrivé
la classe avait été fermée donc d'un
voilà on était plein de parents avec nos
enfants dans dans le couloir de l'école
on s'est retroussé les manches on a
obtenu avec l'aide de la ville puisque
ils encourent a toujours porté une
attention à l'éducation donc
on s'est retroussé les manches on a eu
effectivement cette quatrième place et
puis à partir de là je me suis engagé
dans la fédération de parents d'élèves a
parallèle j'ai aussi eu un engagement
dans une association pluridisciplinaire
sur lui en cours où j'avais proposé une
activité de randonnée en famille
après bien sûr quand vous avez des
engagements comme ça un moment ou un
autre les responsables de ces
associations vous demande de prendre un
petit peu plus d'engagement dont de
venir à des conseils d'administration et
puis le jumelage est un moment
au bout de quelques années moi je n'ai
jamais fait de tout très longue temps
sur mes associations parce que je pense
qu'à un moment faut passer la main ça
permet effectivement de jours dans
l'action alors dans le renouvellement et
c'est toujours dans le renouvellement
donc au bout de six ans du comité de
jumelage bon à l'époque c'était le maire
de guyancourt dans françois de ligne et
je lui ai annoncé que j'allais arrêter
le côté du map que je souhaitais
peut-être éventuellement recréer une
association plutôt que dans le domaine
caritatives et il m'a dit m'a demandé
puisqu'il était en
en recherche effectivement de personnes
pour constituer sa liste
alors c'était pour en 2007 c'était en
2006 donc c'était pour des élections en
2007 elles ont été effectivement reculé
de l'arrivée pour l'émission et écoutez
moi ce n'était pas quelque chose que
j'avais envisagé la politique mais c'est
comme tout ce qui s'est proposée tous
qui s'est proposé à moi un moment on
prend une porte elle est ouverte on
l'apprend on l'apprend pas mais je
m'étais dit pourquoi pas je fais ce
challenge là et voilà et j'ai trouvé ça
très très intéressant le contact avec
des habitants travaillent avec des
progrès sur votre engagement politique
sur l'aboutissement l'accomplissement
des projets aussi où vous n'êtes pas
senti frustré quelquefois alors après on
apprend alors effectivement le passage
des associatifs politiques il y a
il ya des différences bien sûr après il
ya des choses que mais même quand on est
dans les associations il ya des choses
que l'on a envie de mettre en place et
qu'on peut pas pour différentes raisons
voilà des questions de budget ou des
questions de personnes de moyens humains
dans au niveau politique c'est pareil au
niveau d'une ville il ya des choix qui
sont à faire c'est comme dans la vie on
a toujours des choix à faire
donc au niveau politique c'est pareil à
un moment d'écouté
le maire prend une décision parce qu'il
ya des budgets et tous les élus on a
énormément de projets à apporter déjà le
projet municipal pour lequel on a été
élu ne faut pas l'oublier ça les
habitants nous nous église sur un projet
ils veulent absolument qu'on le réalise
puisque sinon voilà donc nous on a été
élus en 2014 à 67% donc c'est que le
projet qui était portée par françois de
ligné
et ait été validé par les habitants dont
pour jamais oublier le fait que notre
premier engagement c'est effectivement
de se mettre au service des habitants et
réaliser le projet pour lequel ils nous
ont élus alors après il ya des choix à
faire
donc voilà il ya des bases irisation il
ya énormément des baisses de subventions
il ya des choses qui se passent au fil
des ans et qui nous amène à faire des
choix
alors c'est frustrant effectivement il
ya des moments où mais comme comme dans
la vie courante jeudi à rien il ya des
moments on a des envies et puis bon on
peut pas les réaliser pour différentes
position mais et
on accepte ça on accepte ça et puis on
explique aussi voilà tout ce que les
habitants s'ils peuvent nous dire mais
pourquoi vous avez à réaliser ça alors
nous aujourd'hui en cours on est déjà à
4 plus de 80% de notre engagement
réalisé municipal il nous reste presque
deux ans pour réaliser là et on
réalisera la totalité effectivement de
nos engagements
ça fait ça fera bientôt deux ans que
vous êtes la tête de la municipalité de
guyancourt après le passage de relais
avec françois de lier c'est lui qui
était tête de liste mais sur le dernier
scrutin vous n'avez pas de regret est
d'avoir pris la tête de la ville annonce
être engagés de cette manière non non
non non c c'est du bonheur tous les
jours alors effectivement il y as c'est
très très lourd de responsabilités
c'est très très lourd d'être comme
responsabilité mais
tout le tous les liens avec les
habitants défendre guyancourt enfin
c'est passionnant c'est je m'imaginais
pas ça en 2008
franchement quand j'ai accepté
d'être sur la liste de françois delisle
y est c'est se mettre au service des
autres
voilà c'est c'est enrichissant très
présent réussi ça veut dire que vous
serez candidat tête de liste sur le
prochain scrutin municipal
on sait déjà non parce que alors je sais
bien que c'est dans l'air du temps ou
une autre question si dans deux ans dans
deux ans à venir vite ceci dit ça vient
ça vient vite puisque vous avez
vous-même dit effectivement que ces deux
ans presque deux ans que j'étais sever
de guyancourt
après c'est pas pour l'instant un sujet
qui est en débat puisque je vous dis on
a encore 20 % réalisés je veux consacrer
toutes mes forces actuellement sur
effectivement sur la réalisation de ces
projets les habitants les attendent
on a des gros projets le my des saules
on à l'ouverture de l'espace jeunes on a
la place du marché on a énormément de
grands projets là donc pour l'instant
les habitants comprendrait pas que je
commence déjà à parler d'élections qui
ont lieu dans deux ans alors que les
projets pour lequel on s'est
effectivement engagée vis-à-vis des
habitants n'ont pas été complètement
réalisées et puis une ville pour mu en
course et c'est presque 29 mille
habitants ça demande effectivement du
temps sa demande de l'attention et voilà
moi je préfère mettre du temps
effectivement aux habitants et à ma
ville chaque chose en son temps ça
viendra je me reposerai la demanderais à
vitré tout à fait pourquoi tant voulu tu
as fait et puis vous vous poserez la
question nous regarde la primeur de exe
votre déclaration si ça vous fait il ya
un événement symbolique qui va se
dérouler aussi sur saint quentin en
yvelines et plus particulièrement sur
wii en course et la ryder cup qui
approche là ce sera un coup de
projecteur pour la commune haussier
alors pour la commune bien sûr pour 51
en yvelines
même si on part de la ryder cup france
et que bas effectivement je peux
comprendre qu'au niveau international si
plus parlants par les paris de la part
de ceux qui ont tenu à voir mais le golf
est survenu en cours restera sur lui en
cours et c'est vrai que c'est un
événement que l'on prépare depuis très
très longtemps
et j'ai l'impression d'ailleurs depuis
que je suis élu sur les débuts en cours
de n'avoir parlé que de la rigueur que
d'avoir entendu toujours entendu parler
de rigueur la ryder cup
maintenant on est dans la dernière ligne
droite c'est dans quelques mois
voilà c'est on va accueillir plus de
soixante mille personnes par jour j'en
reviens à l'aspect politique on arrive à
la fin de ceux de cette émission à
l'aspect politique on a évoqué le nom de
saint quentin en yvelines quels sont vos
rapports aujourd'hui avec
l'agglomération aujourd'hui vous avez un
poste de vice président ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas pour l'opposition on
va dire aujourd'hui les rapports sont
serein apaisé
alors effectivement
au début du mandat même si nous on avait
acquis qu'il y avait une majorité qui
avait été effectivement qui avait changé
ça pour nous c'était pas un problème
c'était sorti des urnes évoque un souci
on y avait une anomalie quand même dans
le paysage effectivement le fait que
quatre villes étaient et scrutin le
nouveau des vice-présidences à 4-2 les
bernois ils sont appelés les gouvernants
donc là le nouveau président a fait
a fait une ouverture alors nous on a
posé effectivement des conditions
premièrement que lee vice-président se
soient pas des coquilles vides
il ya effectivement un vrai projet il ya
une équipe un budget ça c'est ce qu'on a
eu
et puis à côté de ça on a aussi
travaillé avec le président de façon à
ce que toutes les villes par exemple
soit reconnue au même niveau
donc il ya une équité par rapport à
l'assemblée des villes que les mères
aussi la position des maires soit
incontournable cirque y avait pas
d'ingérence de la communauté d'agglo
d'autres maires sur sur les projets des
villes puisque les projets des villes
sont issus effectivement des listes
conduites par les maires et validé par
les habitants donc tout ça est une
charte de bonne gouvernance aussi qui
est en cours de rédaction
donc tout ça le président l'a acceptée
maintenant
c'est pas tout tout tout n'est pas
forcément réglé
moi je garde ma liberté aussi de parole
et le président le sait que
le jour où ça remettra en cause est ma
ville et mes valeurs
de toute façon je m'exprimerai voilà
deux questions pour terminer c'est
habituel dans ce café politique
votre livre de chevet alors désolé mais
en ce moment pas beaucoup de temps de
lire des livres
effectivement plutôt des brèves
d'actualité ou des choses comme ça alors
pour être très franche avec vous les
livre que j'ai en masse c'est ce que je
prends à la médiathèque pour lire à ma
petite fille
voilà très bien donc le livre de chevet
se situe plutôt sur des mais voilà je
lui sers des livres pour pouvoir lui
dire c'est les seuls vrais livres
effectivement que j'ai actuellement
parce que le reste c'est des
soit des journaux techniques soient
effectivement des fils d'actualité que
je suis est le dernier film que vous
ayez vu c'est un dessin animé peut-être
non non non parce qu'elle est trop petit
encore pour aller effectivement au
cinéma alors le dernier film c'était la
villa de guédiguian sur suran trop
d'immigrants donc voila merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce même café
politique
[Musique]